you're welcome to this video playing
tourist us to wistance from Italy let's
see what we got six is a flexible and
jangly to all kinds of lines you have
the only Bishop b4 jacket sometimes
culture carers defense very solid play
and ya can be recommended for black but
of course you need to have fun the
French defense already okay so we got
the position that it's very similar to a
Dutch defenses play de delayed f5
captured a play g3 probably development
to d3 of the bishop doesn't really help
yeah I'm not sure okay he's going for a
stone wall also d6 was possible the
principal alternative it looks a bit
strange to play the stone wall without
the dark squared bishop but I've seen
numb I've seen this display by a good
player so it's um it's not totally
hopeless okay the Queen I thought um
wasn't doing much on d too so I'm
regrouping it mmm man 1 now can you take
on see farm probably not okay but better
make sure he doesn't yeah I had this
idea with p3 night be to d3 regrouping
the night too
show the vital e5 square wow
yeah maybe maybe I I'm not sure maybe
this is really a good plan for black
Bishop a six now I have Queen a4 though
that it's not great
I'm should a six again Queen a four I
think
yeah drew we want to say useful anyway
to a pose on the be line or the beef
I'll gal probably should play 93 at some
point to get the knight to e5 yeah if I
go see 5 he probably will play Knight f7
and then e 5
hmm
I don't really want to take on d5 but
maybe that one maybe 95 attacking c6 and
if it takes five de I can play 93 later
too kawaii five maybe this is an idea
yeah 9007 a half three four yeah why not
why not I just thought about 97
hmm why is he not recapturing okay ed
was a very strange move so strange that
he spent time iam hmm yummy this son
didn't lead to much
try to combine Queen takes a six and the
ideas like night f form he can take on
d3 and play 92 what I can take be aids
um it's not um not so dangerous or not
so dangerous is a strange way to phrase
it it's just so not great okay I didn't
see that move ok but I can I can play on
now nitey to work and play would be
seven well looked like him I didn't plan
any of that yeah this is actually good
for what 92 would be some I don't really
see how he proved how he protects e6 now
besides Queenie aid of course but then I
take a seven
okay taking on his happiness down
something better you if i go here first
yeah why not lettin the night doesn't
have any squares yeah now he's got some
issues on the background I hope wait
wait wait not so not so quick I take a
seven is going to play book f7 hmm it
looks like I should win material him I
don't see it at the moment though
okay let's grab this first okay he
didn't play would have seven yeah okay
okay seven isn't a great move anyway on
an attractive move that same it still
doesn't have any squares him okay that's
not be too sophisticated
we ate the sir maybe not the best move
but it should should keep everything
under control check check here I can
check here Playworks you want something
like that check
yeah this wasn't the best continuation
pretty sure check
it's not so easy to play even okay I can
take him don't don't really see the
problem with that 3g eight medium twin
g8 med and 26 I don't see okay yeah
check check add a four-time burnage for
medium check checkmate we yeah I don't
know I should have had something better
after that 92 Leah this I have a hard
time to believe and how do I win now I
didn't I didn't see it Queen a form okay
no I didn't dad in spot cuneiform it's
not not not a difficult move the thing
is I only thought about attacking the
night with let's say queen a five but
Queenie was such a stronger after work
see a time playing this one and it's
trapped gas was strong this probably
keeps keeps on edge but it's check Wow
i dunno Queenie true now is very strong
better for black even yeah he
threatening between a night f3 check and
if i take chance made into wow yeah this
would have one for black chang amazed
amazing yeah this is basically suicide i
guess wow yeah then the ticketed one
strange game strange game alright i hope
you liked it thanks for watching